I am directing our house committee to
open a formal impeachment inquiry into
President Joe Biden
this logical Next Step will give our
committees the full power to gather all
the facts
and answers for the American public so
it's official Kevin McCarthy giving the
green light for an impeachment inquiry
into President Biden the house Speaker
telling Americans that the GOP has
exposed a culture of corruption in the
Biden family the move gives Republicans
more power to investigate how Hunter
Biden leveraged his dad's brand to rake
in foreign cash and whether President
Biden was involved the White House
calling it extreme politics claiming
there is no evidence of wrongdoing by
President Biden
President Biden because President Biden
didn't do anything wrong the purpose of
what they're doing is a politically
motivated far-right extreme series of
attacks on the president and his family
that are not rooted in the truth
Democrats and the media ready to defend
the president
oh my god really oh my gosh you know oh
it's devastating
oh don't do it please don't do it there
is zero evidence of any malfeasance on
the part of President Joe Biden there's
been no evidence and so they're using
this word inquiry there is no direct
evidence they would be going forward
with an impeachment inquiry based on
lies the craziest people on the back
benches in the House of Representatives
are demanding that Kevin McCarthy called
for an impeach this is
the White House's dream the impeachment
inquiry is absurd the American people
want us to do something that will make
their lives better not go off on these
chases and witch hunts
but could there be one upside for Biden
during the inquiry Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is pointing out that vice
president Kamala Harris could be the
president's impeachment insurance
and I also look and think about who's
waiting in the wings with Kamala and I
think you're right in terms of the
aptitude uh even though she's a lot
younger I think she's basically been his
impeachment Insurance because people
know no matter how bad Biden is nobody
wants Harris and that's just the reality
and that's a sad situation America finds
ourselves in
Jesse Waters is it the next logical step
it is and it's going to be funny to
listen to Democrats here there's no
evidence for the next six months because
here's just three pieces of evidence
right here that's off the top of my head
okay so uh Putin's billionaire buddy
wires the Biden family three and a half
billion dollars and then they sit down
for dinner with Joe Biden and then Biden
leaves her off the sanctions list twice
right there you could open an
impeachment inquiry or how about when
Joe Biden flies his son that shiny comes
back with a bucket of cash and then gets
on the hey guys you better pay up the
rest or my dad's gonna get revenge on
you and what do you know Joe Biden
starts writing the Communist Chinese
guy's daughter's recommendations to get
into Brown and then they Grease the
regulatory process so the Chinese can
buy an American car company oh yeah and
then hunter gets that diamond for about
75 000 that he lost because if Malia
Obama got a diamond and then President
Obama went soft on the country that gave
it to him I'm sure that would not be a
big deal at all and then who else do we
have we have uh Biden flies the sun down
to Mexico City Hunter meets with the
president of Mexico and Carlos Slim
comes back with money and then complains
guys I've gotten all of your clients
into the White House to meet with my dad
and you haven't paid me a dime where's
the cash
they can't answer those three situations
so I can't wait till they have to answer
about the burner phones the 20 shell
companies or Joe Biden on a voicemail
saying uh son I read the Times piece
about your shady deals in China you're
in the clear now how would he even know
if he was in the clear if you didn't
know what his son did and how do you not
know what your son did if you call your
son every day for the last 20 years hey
son how'd you get the Porsche panorama
hey son where did you get all the money
to take me to Saint Crowley eight times
in a row did you know that the Biden's
vacationed in Saint Croix notorious tax
shelter eight seasons in a row I mean
Joe didn't pay for that that money was
coming from Hunter or from Jimmy and
Jimmy was putting his brother up in a
nice Naples Resort that he purchased
right off the coast who paid for that
Jimmy's a scam artist he doesn't do
anything and then all of a sudden he
didn't do anything to return the money
well he didn't pop the Chinese spy
balloon cover it up for the lab leak
he's been covering up for all the
countries that have been paying his
family so they're going to have to
answer for all of this there's a
mountain of evidence that they can't
confront and they keep on saying this is
the best thing that's ever happened to
the Biden White House I don't think Joe
Biden believes that that's why I wanted
to ask Jessica Morning Joe says this is
the White House's dream scenario is that
the case
no that's a very silly dream to have I I
think a dream scenario is you pass a
whole bunch of more legislation you have
a resounding victory in 2024 you live a
healthy life into your 80s and you have
a great eight years that was the dream
scenario that has long since passed as a
possibility and a lot of that is due to
the impact of Hunter Biden but as always
I am thoroughly entertained by Jessie's
diatribe and I learned some new things
but it's strange that members of the
Republican Party who serve in Congress
don't agree with him so much so that
they're on record saying things like
this David Joyce Congressman I'm not
seeing the facts are evidence Dusty
Johnson there's a constitutional legal
test that you have to meet with evidence
and I haven't seen it Don Bacon there
should be a direct link to the president
and some of the evidence I think we need
to have more concrete evidence to go
down that path and then Ken Buck the
time for impeachment is the time when
there's evidence linking President Biden
and I don't think that evidence has been
presented now these are not people who
are Democrats they're not members of the
lame stream media or whatever you want
to call it those are Republican Congress
people
Kevin McCarthy I guess has Amnesia he
has short-term and long-term last Friday
he told Breitbart that there would no
impeachment inquiry without a vote he
also in 2019 went after Nancy Pelosi
saying if she was going to have an
impeachment agree without a vote it
would create a process completely devoid
of any Merit or legitimacy well welcome
to the circus Kevin McCarthy that's what
you've done Nancy Pelosi did have that
vote on October 31st in 2019.
McCarthy has made too many promises to
too many lunatics Marjorie Taylor green
I hear this politicos reporting this
afternoon that Donald Trump was on the
phone with Elise stefanik number three
in the conference the GOP conference
chair talking about impeachment he
continues to do Donald Trump's bidding
now I returned to where I started no one
wants an impeachment inquiry it's never
fun it's not going to help anything but
it is going to show that the GOP is a
fiercely unserious party they have to
keep the government open that should be
the priority you should I don't know
have some plans to make life better for
the American people but know you're
going to spend the next several months
by the way collecting evidence you've
been doing that for nine months already
you just haven't come up with anything
because the evidence that they're
looking for if there is if it exists it
has been blocked from access by by the
Biden family and by the White House let
me just say a couple of things I want to
respond to Jessica and what we heard you
know they're saying it's not rooted in
the truth that this whole impeachment
thing they went after Trump for lies
even the Durham report at the end of all
of it after they impeached Trump for
Russia collusion and lies and Adam sack
his shift lied to everybody about the
fact that I have proof Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt Durham report comes out
and Hillary Clinton says oh I made it up
because I wanted to get the press off my
back and Joe Biden knew about it and so
did Barack Obama but let's let's get
Beyond and by the way the Democrats did
the soviet-style basement impeachment
hearing give me a talking about when
they did it in the basement but I don't
have time to go through that review yeah
well that was the second one
yeah now now listen this is an
impeachment inquiry it is not an
impeachment and I liken it to a search
warrant someone comes to me and says
judge I have probable cause I need a
search warrant I need to execute it to
get answers to where I'm headed that is
exactly what this is this this is not
the articles of impeachment this is not
the indictment this is the inquiry and
this inquiry is based upon eminently
justifiable evidence number one
whistleblowers FBI Partners emails bank
records shell company flight logs Joe
Biden specifically Bob olinski said a
witness a live witness says not only did
Biden know about the business he engaged
in discussions with Bob olinsky about
the business Devin Archer another
partner says he was allowed into the
White House and Joe claimed no role with
Hunter's foreign
Partners Devon Archer says that's
categorically untrue it was a lie the
pseudonyms Joe Biden is sending emails
from the White House to Hunter Biden
under various names about what's going
on in the in the White House and swerwin
visit another partner visited the White
House and the Biden red residents 19
times he was in business with Hunter and
finally Joe is on 20 calls with Hunter's
business associates talking about of
course the weather so you know I don't
agree with these people that say you
know if you can't kill him don't go
after him look they didn't have a senate
uh they didn't go against Trump in the
Senate they weren't able to but they
impeached them twice and we know that
they were absolute lies and at this
point the irony that there's no evidence
is a joke because they're stonewalling
it and the amazing part is it's the
House Republicans that are bringing this
out and not the Department of Justice
which is also hiding and doing work for
the bidens okay Greg you wanted to go
first but I made you wait until the end
I have so much to say we don't have much
time yes okay you know what they say
payback is a and this payback is
going to be one big Joy Behar zero
evidence doesn't matter because the
first Trump impeachment there was more
evidence for Bigfoot and the media
gobbled it up like a bowl of Xanax and
spaghetti so it's your turn in the
barrel you better get used to it I'm
against impeachment especially since
during the first impeachment we delayed
our coveted response by a month for that
because the Democrats they can't do two
things at once they can barely do one
thing at once if you look at the border
and you look at crime and you look at
the economy so they they completely
screwed our country when it came to
covid uh where am I obviously all of the
evidence on Trump was coming from Adam
Schiff which he did not even wasn't even
able to display he got away with that so
if the media cries and the Democrats
Bellow I say to quote Barack Obama you
built that so STFU I won't tell you what
that stands for Dana because you're a
sophisticated lady the fact is
everything that the Democrats accused
Trump of they've done corrupt family
Biden influence peddling Biden sowing
conflict and hate among the American
public Biden lying like a Nigerian
prince Biden so if anybody deserves this
it's him in prison I hope he dies his
hair so he looks better and again I
wanted to I want to just bring us back
to the first impeachment where it was
about the perfect phone call now we know
that he was right that there was
something fishy going on with Joe Biden
and with the Ukraine's and the damn was
like oh my God this and now we know
they're right that he was right all
along he was wrongly accused it was the
guilty party that then accused him so
you now know that after months and
months and months and months of being
told that all of Europe one of the
Ukrainian prosecutor out no one can name
these people they'll come up with one or
a few but they're bogus sources okay Joe
took credit for that so again it's time
for him we need to also to stop
pretending that Joe and Hunter's
relationship is a familial one it's a
financial one right I'm on team Hunter
not team Joe Joe used Hunter to make him
rich without getting his hands dirty so
let's not obsess on Hunter he Joe's head
of the operation I'm tired of Hunter
getting all the blame when Joe's the
dude behind it it's a political version
of Paper Moon remember that movie the
parent and kid grift that's what you're
watching right now so I'm here for this
if that makes me a hypocrite I'm gonna
Revel in it the New York Times you don't
have to put it up but they basically
said the possibility of a Federal
indictment of Hunter stunned the
president yet the bond between him and
his only surviving son is Ironclad It's
Gold Bond coming up Democrats are still
trying to lock up the dad whose daughter
was sexually assaulted by a biological
male hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else